you're not ready to go to the gym why
not dance like JLo and work out like a
Cirque du Soleil performer right in your
living room yeah rocky spoke with a
local pro dancer that's ready to get you
moving here's their conversation johanna
rhymes with madonna as you said thank
you so much for having me personally i
love dance classes and dance workouts
amazing yes it's such a great way to get
fit and get your body looking sharp and
right for the summer yes because I see
you and you are gold so can you tell us
first things first like what's your
relationship to Las Vegas and what do
you do here well I've been living here
since 2009 I actually moved into the
city to work for Cirque du Soleil what's
your experience like on the Cirque du
Soleil stage oh my gosh it's like no
other working for Cirque is such an
incredible experience because you know
as an artist as a performer as an
athlete it's the pinnacle it's the
highest you can reach as far as your
career goes during this time of course
everyone is stuck at home still if they
want to be and they're not really ready
to go into workout classes or the gym
yeah yes so you are giving us virtual
dance workouts correct yeah I think
during this time when we've all been
stuck at home one thing that we've
realized is that with a little
creativity you can get fit in your
living room during this time I've been
offering a lot of virtual classes so
I've been corresponding through my
computer screen to help people get fit
at home and what are the type of classes
or dancers that you offer because I'm an
aerial Acrobat I do aerial acrobatic
classes I also do acrobatics call
classes I do contemporary dance classes
and then mostly during kovat I've been
doing a lot of personal training and
group fitness classes so these are
fitness movements that anybody you don't
have to be an acrobat anybody can do
them in their own home to help
themselves get fit okay well you know
after receiving so much of your energy I
just feel like I need to take a little
class with you that's
so the first thing I'm gonna have you do
is step your feet really wide wider than
your hip okay beautiful all right so
from there I want you to take your toes
and turn them out away from your hip
just like at a 45 degree angle beautiful
then you take one hand put it behind
your head you can take your other hand
and put it straight out to the side with
a nice big open hand and then you're
gonna bend that knee yeah it's beautiful
now from here you're just gonna bend
into that side and reach behind your leg
and then bring yourself back up good do
that again go down and up you're also
probably gonna feel the longer you stay
here that your butt starts trembling a
little bit Cooper yeah what I need sorry
can that little lift from underneath so
how can people get in touch with you and
get you know become part of these
classes the easiest way to do it is on
social media so you can reach out to me
on Instagram my handle is my first and
last name Johanna sepak e ar e al don't
honest a pecky real there you go JC